i think it was the debut of wired
magazine when it first came out
that i was like i fell in love with um
these images of the future i became an
intern for the institute for the future
and actually wrote my dissertation on
them but then i also realized
wow the future is overwhelmingly white
here so when i
became immersed in the professional
areas of foresight with the institute
for the future
you know they have a tradition of really
talking about the future
and pioneering that tradition as a
non-profit
they've also you know had to have a
variety of clients
that are more corporate focused more
consumer focused you know practical
and it makes sense it's you know they're
trying to you know survive as futurists
right it's not easy and so in that sense
though
it leaves a gap right because if you're
just talking about
how people are mapping how corporations
are mapping out our lives
10 to 50 to 100 years from now or how
consumers will spend their money in the
future
you're you're glossing over a lot of
people's in the world that respond
to imagination differently what it means
to me
is that you know after years of growing
up
and largely not seeing black people
represented in the future
you know every straight white male gets
the privilege of having
seen their own superhero someone
reflecting them
in movies of science fiction and fantasy
so we see george justin and his wife and
the closest thing that you get to
resembling a black figure is maybe the
sassy maid
you know the robot who's had enough at
times
i contributed to this wonderful
anthology called afrofuturism 2.0
i have chapter eight it's called playing
a minority forecaster
in search of afrofuturism where am i in
this future stuart brand
it's a nice homage to stewart in many
ways and also a critique
but it's good because really it's about
how do we find our futures to make sure
that black futures matter here
so i share a dream to ensure
that long oppressed racial minority and
diverse voices
can articulate themselves in the futures
imagined
in the practices of long-term thinking
and in the professional areas of
foresight
celebrating the black imagination